give your background on how you got
involved with the kgb this guy asked me
point blank he said well are you in or
not and i went like huh but
i don't know if i'm good enough i'm not
trained i need to learn this this and
this he said don't worry about it we'll
train you did you ever meet yuri
the man was a fraud he was not kgb how
do you know that i don't know for a fact
okay so you're just speculating we've
been speaking for 45 minutes the moment
yuri came up that was the first time you
crossed your arms and you seemed upset
no i i tell you what makes me upset tell
me the conservative end of the political
spectrum in the united states is
shooting the cause in the foot you ended
up doing counter surveillance for us
yeah like sort of turned
the weapon that they gave me against
them well it is what it is this is how
it works in espionage
we have a special show for you today
today my guest is a former kgb defector
of almost 15 years 10 years when he was
active spying on the us
and the story is absolutely fascinating
on what happened with him he wrote a
book in 2017 called deep undercover my
secret life entangled allegiance as a
kgb
spy in america with that being said jack
barski aka albrecht dietrich thank you
for being a guest on valuetainment
very good you win you win second prize
for pronunciating my name because it's
really hard there you go let me tell you
something my daughter actually changed
her last name
to uh
my my birth name and she can't pronounce
it either
she change your life changed her life to
your birthday
she she was uh
uh chelsea barski and she changed it to
chelsea didly wow
and that that listen that says how much
your daughter loves you to be able to do
something like that you know it's oh yes
we we have a very special relationship
it's very obvious i saw some of the
videos and it's it's very obvious how
big of an impact she had on your life
when you said she made me softer and i
wanted to change my life and it even got
you emotional about it but
let's get right into it so jack for for
those that don't know you
uh
your story is written all over the place
uh i've known your story for a while
i've been following you for quite a few
years uh in regards to your story
you might take in a minute and maybe
give your background on how you got
involved in the uh with the kgb
all right
i give you the uh
the cliffsnote version and
because otherwise it gets too long sure
i was born four years
after the end of world war ii in eastern
germany
which was occupied by the soviet union
by soviet troops which became the german
democratic republic
which was a
a very very
trustworthy and trusting vassal states
to the soviet union almost an extension
of the soviet union uh was run by the
communist party and uh
first of all
it was i grew up in poverty i grew up in
a village
a relatively small village
the area i grew up in was one of the
poorest in germany to begin with but
when
uh
when the soviet troops came through on
their march towards berlin they
destroyed a lot of stuff and that's not
a surprise you know
and and and uh
then they took half of what was left
over that was useful they took it out of
the country for reparations they had
every right to do so
uh so we uh we had just barely enough to
eat and it was always it was a fight for
survival the first few years i can't
remember that because
i was too young
uh but i i just can't tell you one thing
uh
an anecdote my mother once told me she
she said you know occasionally i would
get an
an egg
and i make a meal for the three of us
so i really didn't ask
what she stretched that egg with
i was afraid of the answer yeah
um
early on the communists did something
really really smart
they focused on education they focused
on the next generation coming up and
they they trained a whole bunch of uh
teachers
in the in in the new ideology
uh
and uh
and we we got an excellent academic
education but we also got a phenomenal
amount of indoctrination okay so uh
the communist ideology uh
was involved in with almost everything
you were doing regardless of what it was
it could have been sports or theater
uh
the arts and of course school
so i grew up
with the firm knowledge a that there was
no god and b that uh
communism was the future of the world
and that we it was our responsibility as
a next generation
to
precipitate the move from the rat system
that was in the west like all the not
the old nazis and
the bad capitalists and
and eradicate poverty in the world so we
could finally establish
paradise on earth for the working class
i bought into this it was probably
next to impossible not to there were
some dissidents
but typically there were people who
had a glimpse of the other world the
west they had like people who came over
relatives and they came over and they
brought nice presents they brought
oranges which we
i didn't see until maybe i was 10 years
old
and so they started looking a little bit
i had no
i hadn't we had no such connection and i
had no reason to look
um particularly as i entered college um
i was a pretty smart kid
and as i entered college in my first
year i established a reputation of being
the best
and in the next couple of years
uh i enhanced that reputation to an
extent that i already had a name for
myself
and i was it was quite clear that i was
i wasn't thinking ruling class ruling
class i would but i was going to be one
of the people that
you know helped everybody else that were
not quite as smart to live a good life
so i i never really investigated uh
you know
the potential truth or not elect thereof
of our ideology of our history i just
believed it because it was good for me
and so
the uh the climax of all of this was
that at one point i would see i
received
a national scholarship that was
limited to 100 concurrent holders in the
entire country
that
put me on the map that put me on the map
as far as the kgb researchers is
concerned are concerned i was a party
member i was an excellent student
and
i do believe i don't know this for a
fact but i do believe that the
stasi east german police gave the
the kgb access to files and by the way
there was a file on everybody in the
country and there i was a standout he's
really smart and he believes in
communism let's talk to him
and i can stop right here but i can go a
little further yeah if you don't mind
stopping right i got a couple questions
for you so uh my question is when you're
there and they're
indoctrinating you know you said you
know communism one of the things they
did right is education they got that
part right which we're seeing a lot of
that in america as well we'll go into
that momentarily but
i asked gary kasparov which i'm sure you
know who gary kasparov is and the
question i asked him i said so
when you lived in russia and you're
going to school and you're being told
communism is the greatest system uh in
the world economical system how are they
selling america and capitalism to you
what was the ways they sold capitalism
or rich people to you
ah
let's see if
we are in agreement um we
obviously you couldn't completely uh
block out information that came from the
outside
so there was always this knowledge that
the standard of living in west germany
was higher there was knowledge that the
united states was pretty rich but here
was the explanation
they they stole all that the wealth from
the third world
you know the you know they got the
bananas for nothing from guatemala
and and uh you know and just like it had
slave labor in in third countries and
that's why they were able to sort of
bribe
their underclass to have a reasonable
standard of living so the rich people
would be left alone
that was uh what we bought
of course it wasn't true but
what a thing to say so they got
banana from guatemala for dirt cheap
so
so was it more slave labor they're not
paying people fairly they're getting fat
rich and everybody else is doing the
work is that kind of the uh route or
whatever you know also the international
you know the multinational uh
concerns that uh like oil companies they
would go and drill in
in countries like venezuela and take all
the oil out
right so stealing
uh cheap labor suppression making sure
that the countries that had the wealth
would not benefit from that wealth and
and one of our uh the focus on of the
the communist camp was to
uh
undermine american uh
influence in the third world
you know to get into africa get get into
asia and so you remember that at one
point
there was in the u.s there was this
domino theory
uh
in in asia when when one country falls
the others might fall too
it wasn't totally off the wall
there was an active effort to actually
do that whether it would have succeeded
is another story but
so so go back to that go back to that so
as a kid when i was coming to growing uh
a growing up you know family they had
two different philosophies one believed
in imperials and one believed in
communism
but always when it came down to
creating hatred towards a system it was
linked to a face or a name
so you know it was this person that
person so your hate was linked to which
personalities during that time was it a
president was it a author was it a
philosopher who did they sell hate to
okay it was usually the politicians so
but it it depended uh on the
time i remember growing up i i started
reading just a little bit and we had
these magazines for for kids uh there
were caricatures in those days of
president eisenhower
in eisenhower became sort of a curse
word
so we hated eisenhower we hated all
american presidents we hated jimmy
carter with his damn you know human
rights policy but then we really hated
ronald reagan
why why ronald reagan above others
because he was the guy that lowered
taxes and capitalism and all that or no
because because uh he was a warmonger he
i mean this was uh
this was spread throughout the kgb
because because the kgb actually
believed because that ronald reagan
because of his christian
background
uh saw himself as
a helper to god to bring about the end
of the world we thought he would start a
nuclear war period
so by the way it's very interesting
one of the presidents
we didn't hate
we actually pretty much liked
and that was jfk yeah
uh now this was more uh just like
because of his appearance not
necessarily because
it makes sense
the charisma of an individual plays a
huge role in i still remember there was
there was nobody in my generation that
that would not remember where they were
when they heard that kennedy was
assassinated it we just like oh my god
what's going to happen now kennedy
actually
kennedy actually
was a pretty lousy president
particularly when it came to foreign
relations
yeah so i mean
many people would agree with you on the
fact that this guy was admired love
because of his hollywood type of a
personality where he was the first
hollywood president that president that
we had if you really think about it
right
reagan pre trump priests some of these
other guys that uh were hollywood but
go back to the story on what you were
saying so they found out you're a great
student you they found out your card
carrying communist they said this guy's
pretty smart he's pretty intuitive he's
stand out let's figure out a way so go
from there that part of the story
all right so i i'm now sort of making
this up
they the kgb had in
in all the countries where they operated
they had volunteers from that country
that worked with them
and so they engaged one of those
volunteers to
uh you know approach me
and for what some reason they decided to
send a german first i don't know why i
would have gladly talked to a russian
um
so it was on a saturday i'm sitting in
my dorm room
and
there must have been some knowledge for
the individual
who who knocked on my door that a
i was in that room
that was my room and bathe b
that my my roommate wasn't there because
he always
moved uh
uh
back to
he he traveled home over the weekend
and in hindsight i think that we i had a
student next door a russian exchange
student he probably tipped them off
okay so i get a knock on the door and
and the interesting thing is you know in
those days
uh we had almost no outside visitors and
every every knock on the door would
would mean i'm coming in so you get a
knock and the door opens uh there was a
knock and there was no door open
so i knew this was a stranger and you
know when i eventually uh told him to
him
the knock i told the knock come in
so the short guy comes in you had a
cast on his right arm
and
this is really funny it's the only kgb
guy i had personal interaction with who
i instinctive instinctively didn't like
didn't like no didn't like him at all he
had the the charm of a weasel
he had the face of a weasel
and he and he was pretty stupid and i
tell you why i'm saying he was stupid so
he introduced himself as a
as a representative of a local uh big
company that was actually known
worldwide for its optical instruments
called card size yenna still exists in
germany
he said yeah i'm coming from carl zeiss
yano and i just want to talk with you a
little bit about what you want to do
when when you're done uh with your with
your uh with your education
that was an
as dumb
a pretext as you could have had because
he didn't even know that in those days
you companies did not recruit
in universities
you were assigned to a job with minor
exceptions you know the very top
students could pick where they would go
and they would typically stay at the
university now was this guy you know how
sometimes people act dumb like if you
usual suspect kaiser so say acts
crippled or some of these movies was he
acting like he's a weasel or was he a
qualified weasel no no no he was dumb
okay he didn't no he didn't give him
credit i mean he was a qualifier it's
very very awkward
the moment he started talking in my mind
flashed stasi i i knew that he was
secret police and i didn't think kgb
because he spoke german right uh and and
so some and we talked back and forth a
little bit of what it was like to study
and all this and
and then uh suddenly he did a 180 he
said you know what
i really didn't i didn't tell you the
truth i'm actually from the government
so
i i still revel in the idea
i had this thought that i
shouldn't ask him
what branch of the government are you
from
i let it go i didn't you know i i wanted
to hear what he has to say because i was
curious i i was not afraid of the stasi
i
you know i had a clean record so i knew
it would have been something
let's say if not good but at least
interesting
so and pretty quickly he asked the one
question he came
um to to to visit me
and that was the question he said well
could you uh imagine one day
to work for the government
and so i
gave him uh an answer to a question uh
that he didn't directly ask but i said
the following i said yes but not as a
chemist
so he had the answer to a question that
he didn't ask directly but we both had
an understanding that i was open to
continuing to talk about this and
it was quite clear that at that point i
would would have guessed that it would
have to be espionage
and so um he we made a we made an
arrangement to meet at a restaurant and
the following week and uh
at that restaurant he introduced me
to another person you know and
you know the person sat at the table
and he got up and my friend who had
never introduced himself i never knew
his name period not even a cover name
uh he turned to me and said are we
working with our the soviet comrades uh
meet uh um hermann
and then he said i got you know i got
something to do i gotta go so
so one two three i was with the kgb
right because i knew that was kgb herman
right and and that of course
you know made me proud and got me even
more interested because the one thing i
knew that the kgb was
one mighty powerful organization and
that to be associated with that
organization
would be would mean a whole lot of good
i never thought about the danger because
you know i'm a very optimistically wired
individual and you know always danger to
me is always an afterthought usually
after things happen now are you at that
time a tough guy are you one of those
you know i don't know if you've seen the
movie good will hunting where the guy's
a genius but at the same time he's also
a tough guy
who who who are you at that time
um mentally tough
highly disciplined
uh very competitive i tell you how
competitive i was
i started playing basketball at the age
of 18
at university that was way too late
and and i i was i wanted to definitely
desperately be on the first team i was
assigned to the second team in the first
game i played i was hit in the head with
a ball i i had no i had no clue i had no
fundamentals and i was awkward to begin
with i spent one year prac practicing
with 12 year olds
to learn the fundamentals i was not
afraid to you know do that
and i and i made the first team and i
even made the first starting team so so
i was extremely uh
you know whatever i took on
had to be i gave it a 100
okay
tough
um
mentally yes
physically i was somewhat reckless i got
injured a lot in my youth so uh but but
not the you know not the military style
toughness
that was not instilled in me and i
didn't have it it was not innate to me
so so let's go let's go back so you get
recruited this is a proud moment you
cannot believe kgb
is interested in you yeah and this is an
exciting time because you are a car
carrying communist and if you're a car
carrying communist you know it's like
being a yankees fan and the yankees
wants to recruit you to play for them so
this is a very
big milestone in your life so
from there to being trained directly to
going on your first mission what what
does that timeline look like
okay it was one and a half years of uh
unofficial
relationship
loose relationship with herman
we met
sometimes once a week sometimes every
other week
he got to know me he he was the guy
responsible for telling headquarters the
center in moscow you want this guy
and you know all of this for me was this
play i didn't realize it i i now know
that every time we met he he wrote a
report
he had to and he figured me out and they
were looking and i know that now because
i gleaned this from interviews that were
given by high level you know retired kgb
generals
they were looking for a particular set
of character traits in people
about a dozen of them that had to be in
place for
somebody to make a
an undercover illegal sleeper agent
a lone wolf right
uh and apparently you know i
i know that i fit i fit
that that profile
and that's how i actually were really
was really recruited because the year
and a half there was nothing we were
just talking and he gave me some tasks
uh he gave me for instance uh we a
friend of mine went hitchhiking from
east germany through czechoslovakia
um hungary romania to bulgaria and he he
asked me to describe my my impressions
of these countries he he just he gave me
some things to do
he gave me some minor tasks to
uh to uh knock on the door of a
particular family and talk to them and
find out about a relative of theirs in
the west which required a little bit of
a ruse and
stuff like so so i hated doing this but
i as i told you i was ambitious i
couldn't fail so i did it anyway so
what were those characteristics i'm
curious when he said there was about 10
or 12 characters do you remember some of
them what what were they yes i remember
some of them uh not all all attended
that i had written down um
acuity of intellect
quake decision maker
uh
flexible in terms of
situational changes
uh obviously the
hardcore communist
uh my favorite is uh well controlled
inclination to adventure
well controlled inclination to adventure
in other words you have to have an
adventurous nature
uh and and just not not afraid of new
things and and ability to you know very
quickly make good decisions
and and i know i had all of this i lost
some of it but i'm still better than
most
do you remember anymore these are some i
may be listening
while we are talking i i can get back to
you no it's not i'm just really curious
for my own self that was fascinating you
know
flexible of situational changes quick
decisions well-controlled
inclination of nature uh pretty wild
okay so now
you know they they ask you to go to this
family and find out one of their
relatives okay you do that you don't
like doing that kind of stuff but you're
so competitive so you're going to figure
it out because you're not going to quit
okay so where are we going from there
well and so uh
there came a point so i graduated from
college
i had my degree
and i was already an employee of the
university for a while
and at that point
the kgb uh
pulled the trigger
uh i was moved i was uh
sent to berlin
for a three week sort of special
training program
and in that was my first uh sort of a
trip that
looked a little bit like i was spying
because
i had to meet
my my new handler over there in berlin
in a
whom i didn't know at a special place a
special time with the with the exchange
of code words then
so i met him and uh
and i met him uh every other day he gave
me a lot of western literature to read
uh which was prohibited and that made me
feel good what were some of them what
were some of them he gave you oh
particularly newspapers magazines their
speaker
uh the vets item and stuff like that
uh or also the the stan which is uh more
of a sensationalist magazine was and
still is got it uh so just to give me a
flavor of what it what the west looks
like because i didn't have a clue see
there's one thing most east germans had
that i didn't have they had uh west
german television they could receive it
uh we i grew up in what they called the
valley of the clueless
uh
because for us to receive west german
television we it would have required a
huge antenna on your roof
called uh the head of an oxen
and if you had this you had this on your
roof
you were toast so no restaurant i once
visited a friend and uh and i watched
this cartoon and it was so great
uh it was the flintstones in german
but anyway so you know i had to be in
newark i had to be shown rough slowly
what it was like to be in the west but
anyway um
um the um
i also had a a practice trip to berlin
west berlin i'm sorry
um and and i didn't know that how
important that was to them because
because so all i had to do was you know
i i went twice the first time i went uh
uh i took uh public transportation and
uh went around a little bit walked
around
and um
also had a beer and a
sausage was really good and then i got
back and there was nothing the sec
second time
they gave me a task
similar thing just go to a certain
apartment building and knock on the door
and talk to some people and find out
about something i forgot what it was
and i did well
and that was
the deciding factor why they recruited
me because i found out much later that
not all the recruits were able to do
that
because you know for me i was entering
enemy territory
i was entering enemy territory
eventually with the intent of doing harm
and that scares the holy daylights out
of a lot of people i met an ex classmate
of mine who
was in a similar city situation for the
stasi and when he came back from west
berlin he told him i quit
guess what he never had a professional
he never uh
was able to work in his profession
i
succeeded so on the last day my handler
took me to
the headquarters of the
soviet uh military in berlin and i met
this little guy in the office who was
extremely unimpressive
but
the moment he opened his mouth
you know that that guy had authority he
was most likely the head of the kgb in
his berlin
uh and you know he spoke
his voice was loud and metallic and it
was just like they had a phenomenal
amount of uh
psychological energy coming out of this
little man he also smoked like a bandit
um he was most likely in the war
war toughened the guys in in the soviet
union world
nothing toughens you up like war
when you when you see and then uh people
like your friends dying left and right
but by the way just out of curiosity
when a person couldn't make it through
the kgb training after having
been recruited by the kgb
what did the kgb typically do to that
person
nothing
if you were if you weren't qualified
uh they would let it go
uh if
and in my case when the question is
always asked
when they actually asked the question
and i'm i was just about to get to it
this this guy asked me point blank
without
any any hint that to me that it was
coming he he said well are you in or not
and i went like huh
and i said well you know i don't know i
don't know if i'm good enough i'm not
trained i need to learn this this and
this said don't worry about it we'll
train you
i just want to know are you in or not
and we
only hire decisive people so you got
until noon tomorrow to say yes or no
that was a tough night because
because you know now all of a sudden
this became real up until this point i
was playing right
i didn't know it was you know i i was
just waiting and when that came
the reality of that move hit me hard
because fundamentally i had to
become a different person go to another
country
say goodbye to my past to my friends to
my basketball team
and uh start over and it would be
somewhat dangerous
so you know i went back and forth back
and forth but but the
the two things that actually
got me over the finish line a the
the flattery of being recruited by the
kgb and b
the well-controlled inclination to
adventure because i just wanted to do
something exciting that makes sense so
now you go in
uh at this point did they immediately
fly you out to uh
uh russia to go trained by the kgb the
two years that you were there getting
trained
no no no uh
i
i was initially they
thought they would send me to west
germany
uh makes sense right i'm a german
no language and cultural barriers
uh by the way the stasi had about a
thousand
undercover agent in west germany some of
them in the government in west germany
uh so it was quite successful
and uh uh so
the training initially was pretty much
directed towards west germany one of the
first uh pieces of literature they gave
me was the constitution of the
bundesrepublik
but
there was apparently a rule that
everybody who was
trained to do this kind of work had to
learn another language
and i was given the choice
and since i had
really no problem whatsoever with
english in high school i said i'm going
to learn english
and so again i decided i was going to
learn english that that means i gave it
and i i threw myself into this task i
spent at least three hours a day
doing something in english either
working with a tutor or reading english
learning vocabularies studying grammar
and on and on
and within nine months
i had
amassed about 30 000 words
active vocabulary i was able to read the
english novels
uh in the in the original
and that got to
got somehow to moscow
and then moscow said well
they sent me a
tape recorder and said you know
why don't you just say something in
english and
it doesn't matter what it is and i did i
recorded 20 minutes
and and three days later
they
got me on a plane to moscow somebody
just thought they had struck gold
because
i am not aware that there were
a bunch of illegals that were sent
to the united states at the same time i
was as a matter of fact exactly nine i
am not aware that they sent any other
one of those
uh under the pretension of having been
born in the united states
and this they thought there was enough
there
that
i might actually be able to
reduce
the german accent to a point where it
was explainable and i did and that's how
i wound up in the u.s
got it how long did you do training in
russia
in russia it was two years and and
during that time when you were in russia
i saw one of the
uh systems that they had for you where
what they were teaching you but what do
you remember learning during those two
years in russia
uh a lot of the stuff i learned in
russia was actually uh maintenance
because the technical training like
morse code decryption encryption
photography
um and and secret writing all of this i
i got in berlin and so i i just
practiced some sort of celestia's to
stay uh you know to stay fit
what
in addition to english which was the
focus in addition to english what what i
really learned
uh in moscow was counter surveillance
i i worked with the best of the best
those guys were the ones who who would
uh
follow you know cia people
and i practiced with them uh and uh i
did very well
it's funny because you ended up doing
that you ended up doing counter
surveilla surveillance for us
yeah this was this was very important
wow this gave me they gave me uh
certainty in two instances
that was important the first instance
was when when the kgb thought
i was under investigation by the fbi and
i took all the measures that i had
learned and that i had successfully
deployed in moscow and i was pretty
convinced that the kgb was wrong i was
right and the second time is when i
told the kgb to take a hike and you know
i resigned and i was just making sure
that they weren't like coming after me
in some way and after three months not
seeing a sign i knew i was i wasn't
declared so i sort of turned
the weapon that they gave me against
them well it is what it is this is how
it works in espionage
what did you learn with counter
intelligence what were like some of the
things they uh you picked up from okay
well this is the specific strategy you
familiar with the uh term sdr
surveillance detection route i'm not
that is okay that is a
that is a uh uh
a very well known technique uh that is
used by all kinds of spies and all kinds
of countries
and from all kinds of countries that is
you see
in order for
the uh like counter intelligence to
figure out what you're up to they need
to follow you where you're going right
you know if you meet somebody
uh
or if you exchange materials or you uh
you can exchange materials by what we
call the dead drop operation that means
you don't hand it to somebody you you
just drop something someplace
um
and and so in other words
when you leave your house and you are on
our under observation somebody will
follow you
and if you uh pick a route
so that you have
enough of the folks that typically it's
a team
have to come out close enough to you so
you can see their face
uh if you do this often enough
eventually
if you see the same face twice you know
you're being under observation the
difficult thing is
after three hours of doing this and you
didn't see any sign to actually say
you know what i'm in the clear
uh but
because of the i had about
10 practice runs in moscow
and some of them
i was being followed some of them i was
not
and i always was right
uh what was that pretty good confidence
what you because you you know in the
military they used to say stay alert
stay alive right and in business where
they world they say only the paranoid
survive so the average person goes to a
restaurant they're looking at their
table the menu the waiter waitress what
are you looking at what's your lens oh
and and this one thing that uh that i've
always had is is awareness of what's
going on around me and it's that's still
instinctive to me you know people who
meet me say you're constantly looking
all over the place i said i'm not even
aware of it
a couple of other methods um
to
uh find out whether your
uh
apartment or your house
has been
checked out by counter intelligence i
had a i had a real
the the thing with the hair over or over
the door
it's nonsense it doesn't work but i had
i had this chest of drawers where the
the drawers had a bit of an overhang so
when you look at it you couldn't quite
see whether the drawer was totally
closed or not
uh so i left it open eight millimeters
you would have to go underneath
just to see that it's not quite close so
if somebody goes in there and opens it
they will close it
so and the first thing i always did when
i went uh when i got home i checked for
the eight millimeters was always there
um another one
uh you can do is
send a letter to your own
address
from quote unquote somebody else
and you when you when you seal the the
envelope you leave
a couple of spots on
and you don't make a moist so in other
words they're they're not they're not
glued
when the uh
when uh surveillance kind of
surveillance uh
the counter espionage opens letters they
usually do it uh mechanically and then
glue it all together so when it arrives
and this is totally glued you know that
somebody opened it
you know there's some things that uh i
came up with myself this leather thing i
was taught
um
i i was well prepared and as a matter of
fact and that's not bragging it's just
uh
it's a fact i have a friend who used to
work with uh illegals fbi agent and he
said i was by far the best prepared of
them all
but they
they paid a lot of attention to me and
they invested a lot of time and money in
me that's that's so so to me then what
that means is
the the method to kgb is to literally
know exactly who is the most qualified
person to recruit and go get them so you
don't have to over train them they
already have the instinct they already
have certain
uh those uh abilities that they're
watching uh did anything have to do with
family like a bad relationship with mom
or dad or falling out or parents are not
surviving you don't have any kids did
they look for those qualities because
emotionally not being tied to anybody
because historically if you think about
it's like the colder you are the better
you lead
if i had had a a
close relationship with emotional
relationship with my mother i would not
have done this if i had had at the time
if a a girlfriend who i was going to
marry
i wouldn't have done it but the
relationship with my mother was uh
not warm
it was okay you know we weren't fighting
but we didn't it wasn't emotional
and so
they knew that i wouldn't have any
problem telling my mother some kind of a
and bull story
and then totally not explained to her
what i was doing that's correct and the
other
prerequisite was
not to have any relatives in the west
because one day you show up and you see
uncle warner and he says what are you
doing it makes sense
it happens you know yeah of course i i
bet i told you it makes sense to me so
when i read about this and when you went
to the states hey go to
uh uh museums go learn the network with
the elites all this stuff
i saw a format for you your goal was
number one get a us passport number to
enter
into american society number three make
contacts with foreign policy think tanks
number four get close to jimmy carter's
national security advisers the big nav
in order to influence policy why why uh
getting close to him
and if that was the outcome what were
some of the policies they want you to
they wanted you to influence all right
all right
we never went
that far as far as you know what are you
going to do once you get to know these
people the i i got to disappoint you the
brzezinski
situation
was um
it's a it's a canard there was uh that
came out of the 60 minutes interview i
know i never really told him that
they gave blazinski as an example of
somebody who they would be interested in
but i'd never had to test
so so my i was my task was prima there
were two tasks a to
become a sleeper agent become an
american right very important to them
and b was uh
at least i met one
fellow who was who did the same thing as
i did in the united states also
determined
that was his only task
and i said to him when i met him you
know i hate you i had other things to do
so no i was um
my my my focus was uh political
espionage in other words you know
figuring out uh
foreign policy
uh getting close to uh
foreign policy decision makers one of
whom could have been blazing by the way
the kgb i found out at one point thought
they could recruit him no that was a
pipe dream
um and and or at least
influencers you know and so we that's
why the think tanks came up such as who
would you who would you categorize as an
influencer during that time at the time
and that they still exist i was i was
given three organizations it was the
hudson institute in new york
it's a conservative think tank
the uh
the uh the school of international
relations at columbia university where
zizinski actually uh
i think was the head of that school for
a while
and uh for some reason and i still don't
know why but they had a focus on the
trilateral commission you know with
rockefeller
uh so they were focused on
the conservatives now here's the thing
for somebody who just you know jumped
off a potato truck comes in the united
states with absolutely nothing but a
birth certificate
uh to get to a point where they could
actually try to befriend somebody of
that standing in society would have
taken a while
and so
we we show up we thought of a shortcut
and that was brilliant uh brilliantly uh
devised but uh poorly executed
get a passport you know you get your
driver's license your social security
card you know when you're done with this
you go get a passport
and once you've got the passport we send
you to uh such a switzerland or austria
where you can uh
open up the company and
we know ways to
make you very wealthy that way and then
you come back to the united states you
would repatriate the money
i had the education the class the
ability to operate
amongst the highly intelligent people
i would have been a really really
dangerous spy
because you know i could have probably
you know you you come back with five
million dollars lots of money in those
days you any country club will take you
right
and then then you're there you know you
pick a country club where you know that
uh
the the the
the um employees of the
uh
dude what is the the foreign ministry is
not called foreign ministry in the
united states that's you know what i'm
talking about state department
so you know and then you just make
friends and before you know it you know
you
you you're in
um that didn't happen because uh
both
my handlers but probably more so me made
a mistake in
when we
practiced
how to fill out the application for a
passport
i tell you the two mistakes i made
i was too honest
so there's there
was one question uh what's your
profession and i wrote messenger which
was correct
but
i was not a messenger who was working
for minimum wage i was a bike messenger
who worked on commission and i made
enough money to to actually support
myself
that was that was bad and the other one
was uh and the answers were optional
where do you think you're going and when
are you leaving and i left that blank so
you look at the the clark that looked at
this application he put two and two
together he said he's a messenger who
doesn't make any money he doesn't know
where he's going he doesn't know when
he's going there's a little problem
and so
he called me back and he asked me to
uh fill out an uh auxiliary um
a questionnaire and i i was still very
uh hopeful and uh confident i went to
the back i went to a table look at the
questionnaire uh with a pen positioned
and i said oh
first question where did you go to
school where did you go to high school
well i had a cover story with a high
school but
that high school was not ever
never had a student named jack barsky
so i had to
get out of there and i managed to
limit the damage and that i was able to
reposition my application and my
documents because they were still on the
desk of the guy i was i was fast enough
you know he'll be talking about making a
quick decision to take to do that or
else i would have been caught right then
and there
yeah yeah i mean look at the more and
more deeper we get i'm sure you got a
million and one stories i'd like to get
right into it with a couple things i'd
wanna
talk to you about in regards to
uh uh in regards to yuri
besmanov did you and yuri ever meet did
you ever meet yuri
no no you're the first one no you're not
the first one there is a uh
there's an aura around desmanov
that he he built up and
gullible conservatives in the united
states
ate up
the man was a fraud
i'm sorry i'm sorry to disappoint you
tell me why he's a fraud and based on
which uh spezmanov first of all besmanov
was never kgb okay that's a fact
bezmanov
had an association with the kgb
as a
journalist uh his his travel to the
united states is is quite interesting at
one point he he was stationed in india
and he decided to defect in some way
and so he
he uh
disguised himself as a hippie and he
traveled around in india for a while and
eventually he he must have connected
with the cia and wound up in the united
states
and so your bresmanov wasn't much of any
things but he had to make a living
and smart enough he was he concocted
this whole idea how the how the soviet
union had this master plan
to you know in stages to undermine the
united states
yes they had how do you know that
i'm curious
so
from your i was expecting you to say
something like the way you did i fully
expected you to undermine yuri a million
percent because i know your background
and i know which side you are
politically but i'm curious to know from
your end how do you know for a fact he
uh was a fraud how do you know he was
not the real deal okay all right um
he was not kgb how would he the
the kgb was good at something very good
at something and anybody who has yeah uh
has had any contact with the kgb and was
keeping things secret
if they had had this master plan a
journalist who's not even in the kgb
wouldn't know anything about it
number one number two and this is this
is my own
observation
i was trained by some of the best
because i was one i was one of the few
elite agents that they sent in the
united states they had to give me the
best and some of those folks had
spent some time in the united states
as you know diplomats or maybe
journalists
and they thought they knew something
about the united states
and they didn't because what they the
advice they gave me and the stuff they
taught me was was off the wall wrong not
correct and it is pretty much
acknowledged
uh
an agreement that
neither the
the uh the united states knew very much
how the soviet uh um
society operated and neither did the
soviet union yeah but what i'm trying to
ask is how do you know he was a fraud
though how how do you for a fact know
yuri was a fraud i'm curious
no i'm just saying it out loud because i
don't know for a fact okay so you're
just speculating is what you're saying
that is but it's speculation it's based
on uh personal knowledge and it's based
on
um
if he had if the kgb had had such a plan
as i said they wouldn't have told him
secondly i know what they did and i know
you know if you're familiar with active
measures
very much so okay active measures
was a focus
particularly on drop off was and this
this comes this this is factual this
comes out of the archives of the kgb uh
there's a guy who was archivist and he
smuggled out a bunch of material that
bites by the name of mitrokin
and
and active measures were somewhat
successful and that's how you try to
undermine the united states but if that
was the best they had
what was
where's the uh where does the other plan
come from they couldn't even come up
with one what do you mean it makes no
sense stalin came up with it in 1923
where you know
the disinformation program that was come
up with years ago subversion by sun tzu
which the ultimate way to beat your
opponent is to manipulate and think
you're not really fighting them by using
somebody else
in a proxy war and they were very
effective
i mean if you if you're going to say so
so here's what i want to do here's what
i want to do i want to play the clip of
yuri and you know which clip i'm going
to play for you and i'm going to go
through the three steps and i want you
to
tell me which part of what he says is a
complete line doesn't make sense i'm
just curious
we spoke several times before about
ideological subversion that is a phrase
that
i'm afraid some americans don't fully
understand when uh the soviets use the
phrase ideological subversion what do
they mean by
ideological subversion is is the slow
process which we call either ideological
subversion or active measures activeness
in the language of the kgb or
psychological warfare what it basically
means is to change the perception of
reality of every american
to such an extent that despite of the
abundance of information
no one is able to come to sensible
conclusions
in the interests of defending themselves
their families their community and their
country
it's a great brainwashing
process which goes very slow and it's
divided into four basic stages
uh the first one being demoralization it
takes from 15 to 20 years to demoralize
a nation why that many years
because this is the minimum number of
years which requires to
educate one generation of students
in the country of your enemy
exposed to the ideology of the enemy in
other words marxism-leninism ideology is
being pumped into the soft heads of at
least three generations of american
students without being challenged or
counter balanced by the basic values of
americanism american catholicism
the demoralization process in the united
states is basically completed already
for the last 25 years
actually it's over fulfilled because
demoralization now reaches such areas
where previously not even commerce and
dropoff and all his experts would would
even dream of such a tremendous success
most of it is done by americans to
americans thanks to lack of moral
standards as i mentioned before
exposure to true information does not
matter anymore
a person who was demoralized
is unable to assess true information the
facts
tell nothing to him
uh even if i shower him with information
with authentic true documents with
pictures
even if i take him by force to the
soviet union and show him concentration
camp he will refuse to believe it
until he he is going to receive a kick
in the in his fat bottom
when the military boat crashes his balls
then he will understand but not before
that that's the tragic of the situation
of demoralization so which part of what
yuri just said do you disagree with now
let me just start with what i agree with
he talks about active measures and that
is accurate that's correct
he also talks about uh
the uh
the
demoralization of the nation of and he
actually makes a good point
uh this is primarily happened that
happened internally
all right and in a lot of this in my
view started with with the vietnam war
and the the anti-war protest movement
he does not make the connection he
doesn't connect the dots between what
the kgb did
and what happened in the united states
that is not there and he can't make it
because it can't prove it forget about
that i don't care about that what i care
about is how much of what he's saying
actually was done and has credibility
because it's tough to dispute
that russia didn't successfully inject
the spirit of communism and karl marx in
u.s universities and get younger kids to
believe that marxism is the way to go i
mean if you look at some of the surveys
that's coming up right now from harvard
university 64 percent of amer of
students at harvard support socialism
and they don't like capitalism so it so
it was an effective method wasn't it
yeah but the question is how did that do
it and who did it they didn't have a lot
of people in the united states that
could have done this this was this was
home
homegrown
communism and this whole idea of you
know everybody getting along together is
an extremely attractive ideology for
young people you don't need much now
there there there have been uh liberals
socialist streaks in in america in
america historically
uh
going all the way back
and they have grown and they have they
have
particularly taken hold in in
in universities in academia
and
and so i agree that we now have already
two generations who have been taught by
people who beca who became anti-american
during the vietnam war now did these the
soviet camp contribute to all of this of
course we did but the kgb itself and
this is where where i i think i'm saying
that uh there's an office of fraud had
nothing to do with it because they
weren't really capable of doing what he
said they were doing
they weren't really capable of doing
what they said okay
let me let me let me uh
try to
point out the fact of the matter
uh the active measures as as
as i said uh under andropov who was in
charge in the in the 80s active he
actually issued a
command that everybody in the kgb would
should be involved in active measures it
was really important to them yeah but
the department in which active measures
were were executed uh
was not very uh
desirable
so you know director first directorate
the one that did espionage that was the
number one the
did i forgot the directorate that did
active measures uh
that was for losers this is a quote out
of mitrogan that came out of the study
of the archives of the kgb
they had some successes and they failed
miserably in in
many other respects
now i'll give you a couple of successes
j edgar hoover being a cross-dresser
that was planted by the kgb
uh the cia inventing the aids virus that
was planted by the kgb
uh and there were a few other uh
cases where they were
was never a cross-dresser no he wasn't
you're saying j edgar hoover was never a
cross-dresser it was not
i mean
i can only tell you that
assuming that the uh the notes that
mitrogan took in the archives are
absolutely 100 good and i tell you what
uh there is a lot of um proof that they
are that we don't know about because
there's a lot of agents that
uh went belly up after the these notes
that came out so assuming assuming that
he is correct he says that was an active
uh he traces his back uh how this story
was planted
you sure you're sure you're not right
now using some active measures to
confuse the hell out of the rest of the
world because
i'm gonna flip it on you a little bit
because if i look at the seven steps of
active measures that they taught
number one is disinformation blew up in
u.s fake news all these scandals
non-stop
number two is propaganda number three is
deception number four is sabotage number
five is the dece stabilization number
six is the subversion and number seven
is espionage which you briefly talked
about i want i want us to go back to
what our friend here has to say
part two and then i'm gonna come back
and we'll wrap it up he's about to be
done so let's hear what he has to say
this guy that is apparently full of it
destabilization
this time subverter does not care about
your ideas and the patterns of your
consumption whether you eat junk food
and get fat and flop it doesn't matter
anymore this time and it takes only from
two to five years to destabilize the
nation
it's what what matters is essentials
economy foreign relations defense
systems
and you can see it quite clearly that in
some areas uh
in such sensitive areas as
defense
and economy
the
influence of marxist leninist ideas in
the united states is absolutely
fantastic i could never believe it 14
years ago when i landed in this part of
the world that the process will go that
fast
the next stage of course is crisis it
may take only up to six weeks to to
bring a country to the verge of crisis
you can see it in central america now
and after crisis with a violent change
of power structure and economy you have
so-called the period of normalization it
may last indefinitely
normalization is a cynical expression
born from soviet propaganda when the
soviet tanks moved into czechoslovakia
in 68 comrade brazil said now the
situation in brotherly czechoslovakia is
normalized this is what will happen in
the united states if you allow all these
schmucks to bring the country to crisis
to promise people all kind of goodies
and the paradise on earth
to to destabilize your economy to
eliminate the principle of free market
competition and to put a big brother
government
in washington dc
with the benevolent dictators like
walter mondale
who will promise lots of thing never
mind whether the promises are
fulfillable or not your leftists in the
united states all these professors and
all these beautiful civil rights
defenders
they are instrumental in the process of
the of the uh
subversion only to destabilize the
nation
when their job is completed they are not
they are not needed anymore they know
too much
some of them when when they get
disillusioned when they see that marxist
lenin has come to power obviously they
get offended they think that they will
come to power that will never happen of
course they will be lined up against the
wall and shot
but they may turn into the most bitter
enemies of marxist leninist when they
come to power and that's what happened
in nicaragua you remember most of these
former marxist leninists were either put
to prison or one of them split and now
he's working against sandinistas it
happened in
grenada when maurice bishop was he was
already a marxist he was executed by by
a new marxist who was more marxist than
this marxist same happened in
afghanistan when uh first there was
taraki he was killed by amin then amin
was killed by barbara karmal with the
help of kgb same happened in bangladesh
when mujibur rahman very pro-soviet
leftist was assassinated by his own
marxist leninist military comrades
it's the same pattern everywhere
so which part of what he said
demoralization destabilization crisis
and normalization with you know the
marxist leninist ideas spreading in
america which part of that do you
disagree with
well according to what he said we should
we should we way past uh stabilization
he said like two to five years and this
is on a couple of weeks and then they
then you know the tanks roll in and all
that stuff that's vastly exaggerated
what
i i can't disagree with
a lot of the things that he said but he
says it with such authority that you
know he ta he he was not he wasn't a
dumb he was not a dumb guy right what
i'm trying is what i'm trying to ask you
is
we've been speaking for 45 minutes uh
for the first 45 minutes you were very
calm you were good to go
the moment yuri came up that was the
first time you crossed your arms and you
seemed upset what about this man what he
has to say forget about him as an
individual which part of what threat
he's given america to be worried with
are you so upset about no i i tell you
what makes me upset tell me
uh you probably know that i'm quite
conservative
my my ideology i'm i call myself
a
uh conservative libertarian
constitutionalist okay i
i
have a strong belief that
uh the conservative end of the political
spectrum in the united states is
shooting the cause in the foot
by believing in some things that are way
off that they are not that are not
connected to facts not connected for the
truth and they're fall for people like
besmino because it fits it fits their
narrative
and that's where you get these these
people that are way to the right you
know qanon and some some others that uh
that do harm to our cause you know i'm
i have scientific training
who's who's your favorite conservative
president i'm curious
ronald reagan okay
well so so what what do you what did you
think about clinton as a president
for a democrat he wasn't so bad he was
just uh you know a philanderer but uh in
terms of in terms he actually uh
pulled back some of those
social measures like you know work fair
instead of welfare
and he and he
he was sort of almost in the middle uh
and maybe
figures like clinton were in the way of
that that whole scheme that the kgb
cooked up the kgb wasn't strong enough
to do what besan and bezemanov uh
uh says that they were doing and succeed
what did you what do you think about a
trump or obama or biden curious
oh the last two
there were the in my view the worst and
the second worst president in the united
states which one's trump and obama no no
no the last two trump and
bible trump uh
i would vote for him tomorrow
if he were to what to uh run again
um i i'd rather have somebody who knows
how to behave
uh he
he really caused
he caused some damage to the
conservative cause by not listening to
advisers he must have had that advice
not to have that rally on the sixth
because he should have known that there
would be some people some nut cases
who uh who would do what they did and
give the tons of ammunition to the
democrats who think you know who call
this a an insurrection and uprising a
bunch of nonsense but
he should have like
known better but his policies
i can't think of a single major policy
that he implemented that i disagree with
okay so uh so so let me ask you let me
ask you a question uh last 18 months
last uh go from february till today so
whatever that makes it february till
today last 21 months that we've had
right the 20 and what i'm saying is
covet right
uh riots protesting all that stuff
speak from your paranoid side okay speak
from the paranoid side of jack of uh
albrecht um
who was behind
dividing america the way we've been
divided the last 21 months was it
internal was it ji ching was it china
was it russia was it
the the democratic party was it the
republican party was it the mainstream
media media what caused america to be as
divided as we were the last 21 months
well the seats were already in place i
mean we have a as you know we have our
homegrown left and uh
and we we've had anarchists i mean
remember way back when the black
panthers and
and
i forgot this other group that uh
obama's uh ex-friend belonged to you
know the terrorists we've we've had them
and um and i think what happened here is
uh
the ideological uh work that the leftist
professors
did in colleges
actually
bore fruit yeah and more people believe
in this nonsense i mean this is again
they they're looking at stuff and the
desmond officer right they're looking at
stuff and and they're stan it's a
reporter standing in front of a burning
building and says
uh it's a peaceful demonstration that's
some of the things that best number says
are are just like absolutely right on
the money but but he twisted it a little
bit it's i believe it's internal
i believe it's internal
and and don't you think like don't you
think for a person who comes from that
word
the whole sun tzu concept is to make it
seem like nobody else did it it happened
you did it to yourself isn't that like
the whole concept of subversion confused
the out of the enemy making think
they did it to themselves rather we
manipulated
you can do that you that would be
wonderful but we there are people in
this country who are doing it to other
people
i i know that yeah sure i'm aware that
those and those are the people that uh
live high on the
uh we're hog and
same page there
okay yeah what i'm trying to say is
those guys that you just talked about
let's stay on that so those guys you
just talked about
that are doing it to other people
internally
somebody converted them who is the
people that converted them like you get
what i'm saying wait a minute
wait wait a minute it needs uh
it takes con converting a good person to
make a bad person out of them i believe
very strongly that uh
there is a lot of evil
potential in almost everybody and some
people are more evil than others yeah
and and some people are more power
hungry than others and if they get a
chance and unfortunately our political
system
with a uh with a poli a political class
uh enables people like that
okay and and so there's there's some
there's something also
um we need to get back to the
principles of the constitution because
the constitution wasn't set up to have a
political system to have a huge
bureaucracy to have a a vast
a central bureaucracy this is where the
left is going and what and i believe
that communism is not the end of this
kind of development it's going to be
some kind of an oligarchy because you
think those powerful magnets of industry
particularly the ones in in big tech
will just say okay have have have it
give it to the state no communism means
the state owns the means of production
you know that that's not going to happen
there's going to be this is like russia
or maybe like china china has private
industry but god forbid if you say
something against uh the central
government you disappear
so uh it's different it's it's it's a
it's a dictatorship uh by any other name
and and it it
neither communism nor this
uh they're all bad and because what they
imply that the majority of people lose
their freedom to make decisions for
themselves
yeah you know it's it's uh
that's why i wonder
what what part of what this man said do
you disagree with so are you saying the
only thing you disagree with that kgb
wasn't powerful enough to
make make america divide america you're
saying didn't have that kind of power
i i say that
i say that um vastly overrated
uh in in many respects uh
you know i i worked with these guys they
they were they were totally uninformed
about what's going on in the united
states and they didn't know what they
didn't know that's my own personal
experience
yeah
man isn't that like the ultimate uh you
know a guy was at my house yesterday uh
two nights ago and we're sitting there
till midnight we're having a
conversation together and he brings up
an old enemy okay an old enemy that did
whatever he can to put me out of
business
and uh this is a deceptive guy this is a
manipulative guy
this is a
sharp persuasive manipulative charming
conniving he's got all those qualities
all the qualities of a great enemy
so he says uh so
uh uh uh so
you know he starts telling me stories
about this guy that maybe him and the
two had issues together he says so what
do you think about this guy i said i
trust him 100 percent
he his jaw drops
he says what do you mean you trust him i
said you have no idea how much i trust
the guy how could you trust this guy
i said i trust the fact that every
morning he wakes up hoping we'll go out
of business i trust her
i fully trust him so
so the point i'm trying to make to you
is
how how are you so trusting of
the lack of influence and manipulative
abilities a
country like soviet union russia would
have to change
western philosophies you're like
underestimating them no
you got to know the enemy if you want to
defeat the enemy they didn't know the
enemy
they didn't know the enemy well but
we're not talking about the military
we're not talking about
society and and and and that's my final
answer so who was the enemy who was the
enemy that kgb didn't know the so let's
just say kgb thought john was the enemy
but adam's really the enemy who was adam
no no how the enemy functions how the
enemy thinks what's their strength
what's their weaknesses so they didn't
know how america functioned
not really no uh they believed in their
own
ideological
uh
simplifications of of how
the united states and and
and
its economy
operates do you think they they think
they had any idea of you know the the
roots in the constitution no it wasn't
we we believed in our own propaganda and
and the ones and here's the thing the
ones that should have been successful
and should have been uh involved in
uh in the active measures to do what
besnow says were the ones that worked
with me and they
they fell short in my view so
i'm sorry i'm sorry we're not we're not
going to get we're not going to agree on
this point which is fine you know i i i
i
respect your opinion but you
you're not getting me off of mine no i
mean i i don't think i will because you
you know your life is not going to make
you i sat down with a former fbi agent
last week or two weeks ago was it two
weeks ago jim clinton is it jim clemente
jim clemente okay
and uh uh 20-plus years fbi his brother
was an fbi agent fully qualified fbi and
true believer fbi like there's a reason
why he became an fbi agent there was a
motive behind what happened with his
personal life when he was younger we
won't get into that right now so i said
tell me about nurture versus nature you
know like a guy that ends up becoming a
killer and takes someone's life is the
nurtures of nature i love the way he
used it i think it kind of validates
your point here's what he said he said
genetics loads the gun
yes okay he said personality and
psychology aims the gun
and then he says experiences of your
life makes you pull the trigger
so are you saying some people are born
evil and they just can't help but divide
what about the guy who just that drove
his suv into a crowd
that's insane and there's there's all
kinds of like killers and murderers what
about stalin who
and mao who oversaw and hitler oversaw
the killing of millions of their own
people
how how how is how is that
how is that
trained it's got to be in you
okay and i i believe what what the your
fbi man said it's true i actually once
met uh a couple of triplets that were
separated at birth
and brought up in three different uh
families
three different settings and they were
incredibly alike
you're probably familiar with that of
course they did yeah of course they did
a documentary on them yes and i actually
i actually tutored each one of them
so i knew him well get out of here
yes i was in college for them what a
great story
yeah yeah so so your point is your point
is
hitler was born evil it's not the fact
that they made fun of him and didn't
didn't let him go into that one school
or institution that offended him that
made him want to say for the rest of my
life i'm going to get my vengeance
uh
yes that that's my my claim and yes and
there had to be other things that could
fall into place triggers
and
and enablement
right so you know you don't you don't
you cannot act on your evil nature just
just because you want to and you don't
have to be positioned in that way jack i
got two more questions before we wrap up
to finish this off one of them is
honeypot you know the whole red sparrow
story how much truth is there behind
that
a lot also that one is true
oh well yes
a lot yeah oh man yeah that was uh
the
the best of them was actually um east
germany you know but they had they had
the uh romeo's that they'd work with men
yes oh sex and espionage historically
there's always been a great marriage so
to
speak and then the other question is
last but not least to wrap up
uh this is your world meaning
i'm assuming you still kind of follow
this world follow what's happening
follow the news that comes up that has
to do with your world
who who
if you were sitting there and you were
the advisor to trump or biden i'm
talking the last two presidents and they
bring you in
to work as a consultant
who would be your top three enemies that
you'd have to look out for uh if you're
advising
the american president who are the three
enemies we should look out for today
okay number one china
absolutely china
uh
number two ourselves
and number three pick them you know
russia iran
uh
you know iran and iran and
north korea are too small if they start
something they'll they get destroyed
um so
you put china at the top why do you put
china at the top
uh because the chinese
are very deliberate
they have a they have a long-term vision
they always had it
and they they got their act together and
the
they are
slowly slowly getting to a point where
they become almost equal
if not a little bit bigger economically
and militarily
and then uh they're not stopping this is
in
this
and and what trump did he was he he did
the right thing he was actually looking
at them as a as a very dangerous
adversary and now we are loosening those
uh brains again uh
this is this this is definitely a
possibility that one my great
grandchildren will have to learn uh
chachuan or whatever the language is
called
do you almost do you almost need a
president like trump to be able to
handle a
country like china do you need somebody
strong to go up against them or that's
irrelevant and strong and to some degree
unpredictable as long as he is clear as
to why he is unpredictable
because you know they don't want to die
none of them want to die only only the
maniacs want to die the chinese leaders
don't want to die the russians don't
want to die the soviets didn't want to
die so
but watch out for the maniacs
well jack i can talk to you for hours i
appreciate you for uh making the time
and being open to the questions and the
discourse that you and i had this was
fascinating interview
uh uh really really enjoyed it we're
going to put the link to your book below
deep undercover so people can go get it
and find out more about your story we
didn't even cover a half the stuff that
you shared about your life so i i'd love
for them to go find out more about that
but uh jack i'll give the final thoughts
to you before we wrap up i really
enjoyed it thank you thank you very much
that this was very intense
and it was what it was an example where
two people can disagree and
still like each other
i think i like you a lot so no you were
no this was it was pretty hard arguments
and i and then you put me on my toes
particularly since i wasn't exactly
prepared so i had to come up with uh you
know on the spot with some arguments
um that's fine no problem and uh i think
i
at least passed i just want to put one
plug in in addition to my book there is
a podcast out that uh
is about my life
it's called the agent and can be uh
can be
listened to on all the major
uh streaming
audio streaming platforms
it's professionally produced it's really
good because it has people other than me
in it you know it's not just me talking
but it's you know the agent the fbi
agent who uh
uh
who was the lead on my case and how they
were operating but
it's just like and a lot of historic
backgrounds so i'm going to put the link
below i'm looking at it right now the
agent imperative
is a remarkable true story jack barks
get the longest longest arriving no
member of the hkgb illegal programs
operator during the height of cold world
we'll put the link to that below as well
for folks to go listen to it but either
way jack thank you so much for your time
really appreciate it so and one of those
days if we happen to be in each other's
uh uh
neighborhood i would like to meet you in
person i i would love to do the same as
well once we shut this down maybe i'll
talk to you about something but again
thank you for your time
okay well you're most welcome take care
so i'm curious who do you believe yuri
or jack do you do you believe what yuri
had to say or jack comment below if you
enjoyed the interview give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel i got two
other interviews for you one of them is
with clint hill uh this interview got
six seven million views it's the former
secret service agent to four presidents
and jackie kennedy he was the first guy
that jumped on top of the car when john
f kennedy got assassinated the other one
is a sit down i did with ayman dean who
was a former spy for mi6 that used to be
with
the al qaeda it's a very interesting
story he had a chance to meet osama bin
laden very interesting if you've not
seen that click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]